[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
NICOLA BUONANNO:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEBASTIEN MAROTTE: Grazie.
Grazie mille, Nicola,
and buongiorno.
Now, I'm sorry.
I'm going to switch to
English with a French accent.
I will be one of the very few
English speakers here today.
So don't worry.
Actually, we have
really made sure
that all the local team is
going to run this event.
So my name is Sebastian,
delighted to be back in Milan,
really delighted.
I'm very impressed by
the audience today.
I've been six years
already at Google.
And I had the privilege to start
the Google Enterprise business
six years ago, based in London.
So I spent quite some
time here in Italy
during the past few years.
I am delighted to
recognize so many faces.
I think that's probably
the largest ever event we
have been organized in Italy.
And I'm really happy,
maybe, to welcome also
a big, new community, which is
the community of developers.
We have many
developers in the room.
So thank you all
for being there.
Thank you to our customers
also for attending this event
and sharing best practices.
I think this will be a
great opportunity for all
the business managers also
to hear from our customers
about their journey
and about how they
are transforming their company.
So my role here is
to spend 10 minutes
to tell you a bit more where
we are at Google Cloud,
and maybe for the newcomers,
just to understand
what is Google Cloud.
And if you think
about Google Cloud,
not only is it the
fastest growing business
of one of the fastest
growing businesses at Google.
But what is really interesting
is that Google Cloud is really
the extension of everything
we are doing at Google.
Since we created this
company in 1998--
I was not there, actually--
but the mission of Google
was really to match
the world information
and really to making sure that
it is accessible and useful.
So think about it.
I mean, we are all sitting
in companies in enterprise,
small to medium to
very large companies.
And it's not much different.
It's really all about the data.
There is not a single company
I'm visiting right now--
whether it's a hospital,
it's a retailer,
it's a manufacturing
company, it's a bank,
it's an insurance company--
that doesn't care
right now about data.
I mean, this is what
we are living with.
This is our main asset to
really manage our business.
So this is what we are
providing to the world.
In addition to being able to
manage this very large amount
of data, we are providing the
best scalable, open and secure
architecture to
make it possible.
We have made a lot of
investments in the last three
years.
I mean, it is becoming
extremely mainstream.
If you were-- for those who
visited us three years ago,
we were a 3,000, 4,000
people organization.
Now we are close to a
14,000 people organization.
So we have spent
close to $30 billion
on our infrastructure
in our CAPEX.
So we all know that there is
a momentum around the cloud,
actually.
And let me be a little
bit candid here.
I think that we
are just starting
to begin understanding
the shape of the future.
Things are just starting
to really start,
if I may say it
like that, actually.
Compared to a few
years ago, everybody
was welcoming this
kind of event.
And everybody was
talking about the cloud,
about the benefit of the cloud.
You can cut the bill.
You can transform
the way you work.
You can connect people.
You can surface new ideas.
Yeah, true, actually, that
was very, very marketing-
and sales-driven.
But I really believe that things
are coming together right now.
And I think we are really
entering in a new world
where you have the opportunity
to share all these resources
and services that
are now totally
accessible from absolutely
anywhere, any kind of device.
Remember that.
It is five years we
are talking about--
anywhere, any kind of devices.
But today, it is
really improving.
And all these services
are available to you
as an individual or as
a team or as a company.
But these services are improving
all the time, actually.
You're waking up in the morning.
You're switching your mobile.
And off you go.
You have new services.
You have new data.
You have new insightful data.
And you have real-time
analysis capabilities
that you didn't have.
So the power of the cloud is
really available for everyone.
And so not only it is
available, but it's really
empowering as individual
employees and to meet
our professional goals.
And I think if we manage
all of this correctly,
I really believe that
we can dramatically
improve the way we are
performing and the way we live.
So it doesn't work without
the right infrastructure.
And a lot of times,
actually, when
I'm visiting some
customers and partners,
we are being asked,
what makes Google
different from the
rest of the industry?
And I think, at the end
of the day, what makes
a real difference is our DNA.
It's all the
investment we have done
to build this Google network
that you're seeing here
on the screen.
We have an undisputed--
we have a very
advanced infrastructure
with the network we
have been building
with our assets and
the many data centers,
actually, that we have
been building in the world.
Think about the number
of points of presence
we are having in the world.
You can access this network
from pretty much everywhere
in the world.
That gives you, by far,
the fastest performance
to run your data.
And this is really ongoing.
We're heavily investing
in opening new regions.
We are opening new
data centers in London,
in Amsterdam, in Frankfurt
in the next coming few weeks.
And all of these regions
are all connected
with super high-speed fast
cable that we have rolled out
across the world.
So our capacity to stream
data is almost unlimited.
And it's just
absolutely amazing.
If you think about
it, a few years ago,
like just 15 years
ago, it took ages just
to upload a single picture
which was the size of the stamp.
Now every day, we are streaming
a billion hours of YouTube
content in this network.
And this is ours.
But this is also yours,
because we are opening it.
So it's not only about
an infrastructure.
As Nicola said, we
are providing services
on top of this infrastructure.
And you know that these
services are ready,
available 24 by 7 to you.
Sorry, they are
available, actually,
for your personal usage.
And these services,
we are spending
a lot of time, effort,
and investment also
to making sure that they
are absolutely secure.
And also, we care about
privacy and trust.
So we have seven
products or services
that are being used by more
than a billion users every day.
And for our Google Cloud
Platform customers,
they are even servicing a
billion users on their own
every day.
So this is the services
and the platform.
If you think about some
products like Google Search,
for instance, you
wouldn't believe it,
but we have more than 2
trillion search queries that
are being run on a single year.
So it requires an
enormous infrastructure.
And when I was thinking and
talking about different shares,
I mean, being successful
in the cloud is really
about a few pillars.
And infrastructure and
network is absolutely
on the very, very
top of the pile.
You may hear about all of
these stories regarding
data and machine
learning and analytics.
You are not going
to run properly
your data and your
analytics if you're not
at the right
infrastructure that is
being able and
available for absolutely
everyone across the world.
So we have, of
course, many customers
that have built their business
on this infrastructure.
I mean, whether you
are a startup company,
the last thing you
want to do is to build
your own infrastructure.
Or you're a [INAUDIBLE]
enterprise company,
you're going to use
this infrastructure.
So this is the example of
this company called Niantic.
We all know about this amazing
game, which was "Pokemon Go."
And never, ever
"Pokemon Go" would have
existed without Google Cloud.
I mean, this is
the main feedback
that we received from the
team and from the CEO.
The main reason being that when
they launched "Pokemon Go,"
they have exceeded the
predicted demand by 50.
Think about it, actually.
You're launching a new service,
a new business, a new product.
And suddenly, day one, you're
multiplying by 50 any best case
expectation.
And if you think
about it, if you
had to launch this
product or these services
on premise and with provisioning
all the infrastructure
on premise, I mean, it would
just have not been possible
in terms of cost and logistics.
So this is what they have done.
And we are absolutely
ready to take massive loads
and to really manage an
expected peak period.
So it's really an
exciting story.
And what is also exciting is
that "Pokemon Go" is probably
the best story we have when
it comes to content management
and the largest ever Kubernetes
deployment we have done.
And they are using more than
12 services across Google.
The other one is Snap.
If you think about this
company's Snapchat,
they came to us
in November 2011.
And they had a very
simple inquiry.
We want to launch new services.
But the last thing we want to do
is to build an infrastructure.
We really want to focus on
developing our own application.
And it's fascinating to see what
we have done with these guys,
actually with Snap.
It's absolutely fascinating that
you can write a bit of code--
well, a bit, quite
some amount of code--
drop it in a container,
and everything
is being taken care of.
I mean, whether
it's about scaling,
it's about availability,
it's about security,
you don't really
need to know how
to manage and to run systems.
So by contrast, if
you think-- and we
are seeing a lot of startup
companies in the market
that didn't go
that pass and that
are failing because they are
facing a lot of outages issues
by using their own premise
and their own infrastructure.
So at Google Cloud, we care
about all these services.
But at Google Cloud, we also
launch a lot of new services.
And I think that this morning,
if you have the opportunity,
spend some time
trying to understand
what is this Cloud Spanner
scalable transactions
processing system?
It's absolutely amazing.
You won't find any
kind of services
like that across the world.
You can also access our
real-time or near real-time
data warehousing BigQuery and
data analytics with BigQuery.
And we have spent a lot of time.
And every day, we are
releasing some new features
around our machine
learning engines
and around our smart APIs.
It's amazing to see what you
can really build as new use case
when it comes to Video API to
Vision API, natural language
recognition.
We are even working on
Job APIs to making sure
that we can really
better connect
your enterprise with
employees in the marketplace.
And we are really seeing all
of this based on these cloud
machine learning engines.
So when you think about
big data and analytics,
there is a very interesting case
that we have been working on.
And we've made a
public announcement
two months ago in San
Francisco with Darryl
West, the global CIO.
HSBC, which is probably one
of the largest and the oldest
bank in the world, they've
been created 150 years ago,
I decided, actually,
to go to the cloud
and to start with a Google for
all their analytical platform.
Again, go to YouTube
and you will see Darryl.
But what is very interesting
is that a company like HSBC,
it took them 130 years to start
measuring their data volume
into terabytes, just amazing.
Just the last two years,
they got 15 terabytes.
And just this year, they have
to manage an additional 5
terabytes.
It is really the world
of data explosion.
And they did a
traditional journey.
We have large
companies that have
spent a lot of time, energy, and
money in the traditional data
warehousing.
They will recognize this.
They started a long time ago
with a traditional relational
database.
And then they moved, because
of the volume of data,
to the data
warehousing structure.
It was great, actually.
It was great.
When you sent to HSBC
[INAUDIBLE] data warehousing
[INAUDIBLE] was great.
But it became, very quickly,
extremely complex to maintain
and extremely expensive.
So they moved to the big
data era with Hadoop.
And honestly, it's saying, we
have faced a lot of challenges.
I mean, this was
probably the only way
to manage a large,
large load of data.
But again, it was
extremely expensive.
And so it was extremely
tough, actually,
because they had to
feed this new system.
They had to train
their employees.
And very quickly, it became
very expensive and quite
difficult to maintain.
So they moved.
They have decided to move to
Google Cloud Platform, which
was much easier
and much cheaper.
If you think about
machine learning,
we have many, many cases
in machine learning.
And it's amazing.
Every day, we are
meeting customers
that are coming with new ideas.
This is an idea that
Airbus came to us.
And one part of this business
is around satellite images.
So they are managing a huge
amount of satellite image.
So you know it's very
useful for agriculture,
for civil engineering.
So they really need to
build their business
and to grow their business
on this satellite image.
But the problem
with satellite image
is when you picture the
world, you have some defaults.
You don't know how
to differentiate,
for instance, cloud
and snow, just
if you picture the mountain.
So you have to clear the clouds.
You have to separate the snow.
You have to do a
lot of cleaning.
And that was a manual
process that Airbus
was running with just
individual people that
were working weeks, actually,
before coming to these results.
And thanks to machine
learning, automatically,
we were able to analyze
all of this information
and to dramatically shorten
the process to a few hours.
But more importantly, also
to drop the error rates
from anywhere
close to 15% to 3%.
So that is another example.
And we have so many
examples around that,
whether it's in digital
natives or enterprise space.
I'd like to finish on
two or three things which
are very close to our hearts.
And I know we have a
lot of customers here
who are using G Suite in Italy.
This is super, super
strategic to our business.
We really want to help
you, as employees,
to change the way you work.
We want to help you
be more productive.
But being more productive
is about saving time.
Saving time is about taking
care of you, actually.
And we really believe
that we can dramatically
help you to improve not
only your productivity
in the office, but
your life at home.
And if you think about some
very large customers like PWC,
for instance, which
is probably one
of the most conservative
companies in the world,
they have made some studies.
They started the deployment
of Google Suite, G Suite.
And they realized that every
single employee, average,
was gaining nine hours
a week in the office.
So it's amazing.
It's just an amazing
collaborative platform.
You can work together without
necessarily being together.
And it's really a life changer.
This is absolutely fascinating.
And the last thing that
Nicola also mentioned,
and we have many,
many customers here,
it's providing the next
generation of devices.
So you may think about very
conservative and highly
regulated companies
like Charles Schwab.
This is the financial
institution, of course,
in the US.
They have decided to
roll out Chromebooks,
because they just
think that this
is, by far, the most scalable
and secure devices that they
can use in their organization.
And there are some
studies which states
that by 2018, which
is around the corner,
next year, 25% of the
Fortune 500 companies
will be using some Chromebooks.
All right, I wouldn't be
complete without telling you--
and this is a very
serious topic--
that we are heavily
investing in security.
And the next speaker will
tell you more about that.
But we have taken a very
strong and firm commitment
that we will be ready
on the GDPR compliance
by the due date,
which is May 2018.
And we can also start
working with you,
with your privacy and
security team, TRUST team,
actually, on this specific
topic, which is very important.
So I can talk about
security for ages.
But we have special sessions.
So we have more than 800
engineers working on security.
And it's absolutely central
to everything we are doing.
If you think about it,
again, the recent events,
and no later than
yesterday, I think
cloud can bring you a
lot to defend your data
and to secure your data,
which is super important.
Last few things,
partners, Nicola
mentioned some partnerships.
We care about the
enterprise space.
We invest a lot in
the enterprise space.
And we also have recently
announced some very strategic
partnerships with companies
like ACP, or Intel.
This is extremely strategic.
We are studying.
We are co-developing some
applications with these guys.
And it's very strategic, too,
for the enterprise space.
Two things, also, which
are very important.
Number one, at the
end of the day,
companies are coming to Google
with a lot of questions.
This is a very new environment.
This is a very new ecosystem.
And honestly, we have a lot
of questions, which is--
this is great.
I mean, everything you're
seeing is pretty cool,
but a lot of
questions regarding,
how do I start this
kind of project?
What do I need to build this
next generation application?
Who should I recruit?
How do I train my people?
A lot of questions regarding,
do I need to rewrite my code?
Or am I going to be locked
again with a single provider?
So we have so many questions
that we are not only
providing a technology.
But we need to be really
a business trusted advisor
to your organization.
So we have built a very
large organization.
We are doubling our headcount
here in Italy, in Europe,
and across the world.
And more importantly,
we are bringing
more technical
resources in the field.
So you will see
here, later today,
customer engineers that will
help you actually to prototype
your next application.
You will see a
software architect
that will help you to
design the next application.
You will see we have a
dedicated Office of the CTO.
They're really act
as shared CTOs.
And they can really advise you.
And more importantly,
again, for the community
of developers which
is in Rome, we
are connecting our engineers
to our customers, which
is very, very new
compared to everything
we have done in the past.
We are widely opening the
doors of our engineers.
So I will finish
on the one slide,
which is we are also
being asked, eventually,
what is the future?
Things are going so fast.
And again, candidly, I have
been at Google for six years.
It is just amazing to see the
pace that we have been through
during the past 24 months.
And we really believe that
we are entering in a world
where you need an idea.
And you need to be able
to digitalize this idea.
It's amazing to see how
much, with a great idea,
how you can turn that
into an amazing project.
So with the machine
learning, with the smart APIs
I was talking about,
with the highly available
containerization, its so
easy to build and deploy
these applications
that can run, really,
across all the world
on any kind of devices,
and not only on the
devices we are using today,
like a laptop, like
a mobile phone,
but also on sensors, just on the
cloud, and the next generation
devices that we are
building and that
are going to get connected.
So I think that this
data will be shared.
This data will be
updated, real-time.
And this data will
be super insightful.
So I really believe--
we believe that we will
work all we have to, actually.
This is for the sake of working
in the most matter, of course,
and a better world.
So whether you're in medicine,
in medical, in fintec,
in manufacturing, in
retail, you build energy.
You make energy.
Or you run a media company.
I think this is going
to really transform
the way the organizations
are working.
So we are going
to start answering
to problems that never, ever
we have been able to resolve.
I mean, just think about
the medical environment.
So the cloud, to us, is--
the best cloud is the cloud
with the best technology.
Google is really serious
about this business.
It is really mainstream
to our business.
We are investing a ton of money.
And this is what we're going
to share with you this morning.
We are a company
born in the cloud.
And we really want to extend the
services to your organization.
We thank you very much.
And I will pass it
over to Gabriele, who's
going to talk about security.
Please welcome Gabriele.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
GABRIELE CARZANIGA:
Merci, merci, Sebastien.
Grazie a tutti.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
SPEAKER: [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
GABRIELE CARZANIGA:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
SPEAKER: [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
GABRIELE CARZANIGA:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
SPEAKER: [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
GABRIELE CARZANIGA:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
SPEAKER: [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
GABRIELE CARZANIGA:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
Can we switch back to slides?
Thank you very much.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAOLO SPREAFICO: OK,
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
ANDREA ULISSE:
PAOLO SPREAFICO: Grazie, Andrea.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
ANDREA ULISSE:
[APPLAUSE]
PAOLO SPREAFICO: Grazie, Andrea.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
DARYOUSH GOLJAHANI:
Hello, everyone.
Good morning.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- You're on Google and you're
enjoying the collaboration
products--
Mail, Calendar, Contacts.
However, you also have this
need for a business process
to be automated.
- Our agency, they don't have
the money to do a full-fledged
app.
They just need something simple
that makes their life easier.
Right now we have the
blue form because it's
a blue sheet of paper.
- The Wyoming Flexible
Benefits Enrollment Plan--
- You're filling it
out and signing it,
and then they have to data
entry all that back in.
10,000 people, a
lot of blue trees.
- They're able to make
this in App Maker.
- We showed it to
our HR department,
and they were so excited.
- Honestly at first
I was very skeptical.
It just seemed too
easy, like oh yeah,
drag and drop a couple
of little things.
What do I care?
I'm a real developer.
I don't use these
little gadgets.
But as I got to use the tool
more, I was like wow, you know,
this really can do
some pretty cool stuff.
I was able to develop a
relatively sophisticated app
for login monitoring
from ideation
all the way through
the final delivered app
to our administrators from
them to use was five weeks.
And that's just unheard
of in any other kind
of product lifecycle.
- Why App Maker?
Because not everyone is me.
I really like working deep down
in the code working low level.
The great thing
about App Maker is,
you don't need to have
that deep-down knowledge.
People are able to make
these really snazzy
looking applications that can
be used by an entire company.
- I never pictured myself
developing anything.
App Maker is an insanely awesome
way to solve a small problem.
- App Maker makes my
job easier because I
don't need multiple tools.
I can just develop it
directly on App Maker.
- One word to describe
App Maker, simple.
- Quick.
- Flexible.
- Versatile.
- Empowerment.
- One word to describe
App Maker, game changer.
[END PLAYBACK]
DARYOUSH GOLJAHANI:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
MILES WARD: Good
morning, everybody.
I'm one of the ones that's
going to speak in English.
So I'll apologize in advance.
My name's Miles Ward.
I run our solutions
architect team.
And what I'm here
to talk to you today
is about how we were able to
make all of the innovations
you just heard about.
How did we build a system that
was this intelligent, that
allows others to
collaborate, that
creates such a powerful
platform for your data
and for your applications?
The reason we're able to do
that is because we thought first
about openness.
That may seem weird.
Isn't Google full
of computer nerds
that are going to stay up late
and build great technology?
Well, we've been learning from
computer nerds for a long time.
And what the very best
of us have realized,
even long ago, is that
an approach that is open,
that's flexible, that listens
to our customers, that
listens to our partners, and
really builds exactly what they
need, is the right way forward.
And we've been doing
that for a long time.
How many folks use the internet?
Yeah?
Two or three folks here?
The internet was designed
open, built by Vint Cerf--
he's a Google
employee, by the way--
who designed the
protocol that we all
use to connect all
of the businesses
and all the technologies
in the world.
That commitment to
open technology--
they took no patents, no
copyrights, no licenses--
allowed billions and
billions of dollars
of international innovation
that stood on top
of something that's free.
And Google's thought
about the investments
that your business needs
to make and how important
it is that those investments
pay dividends over time, instead
of being something that you pay
for and pay for and pay for.
So Google's made a really
substantial commitment
and investment in open
source technologies.
Almost all of the tools
that you saw today
bear fruit from our investment,
so from work in Linux and core
compilers, 10
years of investment
by Google engineers in
software that's free
and as a leader in the
open source community,
it's not just a one-time effort.
Our engineers have to work
overtime, all the time,
to make it so that these
technologies continue
to become more performant, more
robust, more highly available,
more secure, easier, simpler.
We put 15,000 new projects into
collaboration just in 2016.
You get 2,500 different
projects where we're
contributing source code today.
That's the majority
of the available tools
that are out there.
If you think about maybe
one of the most important
contributions in
the last 15 years
has been our donation
of the cgroup code
to the Linux kernel.
cgroups is what now the
world calls containers.
How many folks have
heard of containers?
Yeah?
OK.
We thought that was a
good idea, because we
saw what a huge impact that
had inside of our business.
Every one of the products
that you saw today,
all of Google's technology
is run inside of containers.
And we know that if it
paid dividends for us
to make that change, that
it's very likely that it
will have an incredible
impact on your businesses.
And that's not just a commitment
to building technology
that's good.
And Kubernetes is really good.
It allows you to
build systems that
are highly available,
that are redundant,
and maybe
counterintuitively, something
that can run on any cloud.
I'm more than happy to see
you build an application which
spreads across us
and our competitors
and your laptop
and my mobile phone
and everywhere else you
want to build an app.
Kubernetes has the flexibility
and the openness to empower you
wherever you want to build.
That ensures that your
investment in this powerful API
is one that pays
dividends over time.
That community, the community
of you and us and our partners
and our customers,
working together
to improve this
technology starts
to sound like an
incredibly fun party.
You have Microsoft and IBM
and us all working together
on the same technology?
That's a different,
better future, I think.
So we're also seeing this
technology and our commitment
to open move through our
different technology tools.
So App Engine
flexible-- how many
folks develop in a language
that none of your friends
have heard of?
You're really good
at Scala or Erling.
Or you want to write
everything in COBOL,
because you work at a bank.
We have an environment
that allows
you to take even that
most exotic software
and run it in a managed
service from Google.
Because you can supply
your own runtime.
That's an open
platform, instead of
one that forces you
down a narrow path.
Google wants to
continue to give you
proprietary performance,
incredible security,
incredible speed, but on the
technology that you choose.
And that's not just open source.
That's technology from
any vendor, right?
We've made incredible
progress in our partnerships
with Microsoft.
I don't know if you've heard
of Perfkit Benchmarker,
but I recommend everybody
take a time to download this
and look at the performance
benchmarks of running Windows
software on Google's cloud.
I think you'll come
away surprised.
Our environment is
not just an OK place
to run Windows applications.
It's an incredible place.
We have the highest
performance network,
the most high performance
storage, and advanced machines.
We just released
computers on Skylake.
Those systems allow you to run
Visual Studio and SQL Server
and all of the broad
suite of Microsoft tools
as if this is their
original home.
And it's not just the thin,
underlying pieces, not just
Windows.
You can run SQL Server
Enterprise 2012 or 2014, 2016.
You can use full .NET Core, all
of the rich tooling you expect,
lots of modules
built for PowerShell,
an incredible rich ecosystem
around the Windows platform.
We also talk to
customers, and what
they told us was that all of the
technology seems very flexible,
but are the people flexible?
I'm not very flexible.
I don't have very
good dance moves.
But our customers
said, I need support
to feel as flexible
as your computers do.
So we started to
think about our model.
Most companies will charge you
a percentage of how much you
spend on cloud for support.
And at the beginning, that
seems like not enough.
I pay you $5 for
incredible engineers?
And at the end,
when you've built
a system that works
right, you end up
paying this kind of success tax.
And we knew our engineers
wouldn't like that,
and so we know
yours won't either.
Our new model for
enterprise support,
which is engineer to
engineer, real Google dorks,
just like me, on the phone with
you, trying to fix your app,
where you pay just for
the number of folks
on your team that
can talk to us.
So support can auto scale.
It's a totally different
model than anywhere else
in the industry.
And we know that it is much
better for our businesses
and our partners.
We've also heard from
customers that pricing
isn't very straightforward.
Pricing is complex.
How many folks think the
cloud bills are easy?
Note no hands are up.
So we heard from customers
that the cost of cloud
can be incredible.
And a lot of that
comes from waste.
In other environments, you pay
per hour instead of per minute.
In other environments you
have to commit capital upfront
instead of automatically
growing your services.
You have all of
this inflexibility
in what was supposed to be
cloud, what was supposed
to be incredibly flexible.
So we've made it so
that any time you
run a computer longer
than 25% of the month,
you automatically
get a discount.
You cannot screw that up.
You can't accidentally
not get the discount.
We've also made it so
that our virtual machines
can be any size.
Do you want a virtual
machine that's
18 cores and 68.25 gigs of RAM?
That's fine.
Whatever you need and what's
most efficient for you,
we can provide at
a low, low price.
That's because we're
built on containers.
We're just a little
more flexible.
If you don't know what the right
size for your application is,
that's OK, too.
We will tell you.
And we actually
give you a button,
so that you can automatically
resize your instance
to the right size.
Can it get easier than that?
We've also made it
so that these systems
are available per minute.
So even if you need an
auto scaling application
to process data
for 12 minutes, you
don't waste 5/6 of the money.
If you know for sure how
your application works,
if you have a commitment
with a customer
to run an application
for years, you
should be able to take advantage
of that prior knowledge.
And we need the same data.
So committed use
discounts allows
you to pay upfront
simply just for bucket
full of cores and RAM.
No specific instances,
no specific zones--
you pick exactly what
you need from us,
and we'll give you
up to a 57% discount.
And different than the grocery
store, these discounts stack.
So in total against
our competitors,
who are already dramatically
more price-efficient than doing
this in your own data centers,
we're another 60% cheaper.
And that's on average.
I've talked to several
developers here in Italy
already, and I've met nobody
that I would consider average.
I think you can save
even more than this.
So I'm really excited
about your contributions
to open source, to a
flexible environment,
to building great
services for customers.
And I've talked to some
incredible customers already.
We're going to bring a
whole set of customers
onstage to talk to you.
Thank you so much
for your time today.
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLA BUONANNO:
Thank you, Miles.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
ALESSANDRA ARDRIZZOIA:
Grazie, Nicola.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
NICOLA BUONANNO: Grazie
mille, Alessandra.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
MASSIMO BERTOLOTTI:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLA BUONANNO:
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
PASQUALE FRESCURA: Grazie
mille, buongiorno a tutti.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLA BUONANNO: Grazie mille.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
[APPLAUSE]